[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt bei
mir dreht sich immer noch alles rund um
das thema einschulung und weil ich so
gerne früher zur schule gegangen bin
ob jetzt wahrscheinlich warum sieht sie
heute so aus warum sie diese frau aus na
ja ich mache keine parallele ein
schulungs torte in ein tief stil und
deswegen habe ich mich in beiden eint
diese kleidung geschmissen andere
geschichte schaut euch einfach die
einstellung ist hause an
deswegen sehe ich so aus und weil ich
ein mädchen bin
end girls just wanna have fun heute
gibt's müsliriegel aber eigentlich keine
regeln sondern kleine miss li snacks die
könnt ihr euren kindern mit so schule
geben ihr könnt sie mit ins büro nehmen
als kleinen snack einfach im kühlschrank
lagern und morgens essen wenn ihr hunger
habt oder einfach mal zwischendurch
diese müsliriegel die ich jetzt machen
werte sind nämlich also bestandteil sind
natürlich haferflocken amaranth
getrocknete früchte also alles was da
wirklich auch so energie gibt und
einfach mal auch schnell den hunger
stillt was aber auch viele vitamine und
mineralstoffe enthält ballaststoffe und
das ganze eben to go also dass man schön
mitnehmen kann und ganz ohne backen
also noch mehr vorteile gibt es
eigentlich nicht ich zeige euch mal
welche zutaten ich nehme ihr könnt
natürlich auch die ein oder andere zutat
austauschen ersetzen wenn ihr was nicht
da habt aber dass es so ein grundrezept
was ihr eben schön abwandeln können ich
verwende dafür 75 gramm mandeln 80 gramm
getrocknete aprikosen 50 gramm entsteint
der datteln 20 gramm getrocknete äpfel
50 gramm cranberries 75 gramm
haferflocken 20 gramm amaranth etwas
zitronensaft 60 gramm orangensaft und
back opladen das einzige was sie jetzt
beachten solltet ihr braucht einen mixer
oder stabmixer stabmixer welcher
bisschen schwierig ihr braucht einfach
was um alle zutaten zu zerkleinern
ich mach das jetzt hier oben aber es
gibt ja auch so die geräte ohne strom
zum ziehen kann man auch nehmen man kann
auch ein messer nehmen alles fein
häckseln
aber es muss weg nicht ganz ganz fein
sein ich werde erstmal die mandeln rein
malen
zerkleinert ich bin heute richtig so
richtig in laune so richtig ab
die aprikosen sind übrigens so dunkel
weil das nicht gespielte aprikosen sind
und wenn ihr diese ganz hellen gelben
aprikosen habt die sind halt meist
geschwafelt da auf die verzichtet haben
es gerne und deswegen nämlich einfach
die dunklen sind optisch nicht so schön
aber das macht ja nichts hauptsache ich
habe da nichts drin was ich nicht essen
möchte
dann habe ich hier die datteln die sind
bereits entkernt die äpfel die
cranberries da gucke ich auch immer dass
ich treasuries finde ohne zucker also
die meisten sind hat echt mit
zuckerzusatz aber es gibt ganz selten
mal welche ohne orangensaft mit rein bis
zum aufweichen und zitronensaft rein für
den vitamin c kick wobei ich sagen muss
dass cranberries auch schon viel vitamin
c enthalten
und ich habe auch viel eisen mit drin
und reisen kann einfach super gut
aufgenommen werden wenn ja vitamin c mit
dazu gibt deswegen nehme ich das
dressing für salate meist immer ein
schuss zitrone mit rein und jetzt schön
vermissen
super aus es gebe ich noch die
haferflocken mit rein noch mal kurz
mixen
das gebe ich alles mal kurz in die
schüssel hier können auch direkt aus der
schüssel weiterverarbeiten aber ich
möchte es noch allerhand mit dazu geben
dann gebe ich hier noch am rand dazu das
ist geprüfter am rand so ein pseudo
getreide aber hat auch ganz viele tolle
mineralstoffe ein großer guter
energielieferant und ich finde die
kleinen kügelchen einfach mega cities
deswegen habe ich immer am rand da und
vista war es ist einfach kurz mit der
hand nochmals durchkneten und dann merkt
ihr auch ob die masse klebrig genug ist
das sind damit sie hält
[Musik]
wir schwören jetzt lauter neue songs im
kopf herum aber okay das war nicht mein
team ok und jetzt habt ihr diese
klebrige masse
das macht echt spaß die zu kneten als
ist am er hätte auch viel spaß dran ist
fühlt sich so leichter bislang vor allem
mit diesen avant kritischem so was für
kinder sind da dürfte die kinder gerne
mit einbeziehen
und jetzt ist es ja eine klebrige masse
ihr könnt jetzt kügelchen formen aber es
klebt dann auch ein bisschen zwischen
den händen
deswegen nehme ich jetzt bei coop laden
und packt ihr dazwischen
ich glaub die hier mache ich auf die
traum ist ein bisschen größer 70 mm
macro platten kennt man meist aus der
weihnachtszeit aus der
weihnachtsbäckerei für makronen und für
plätzchen aber die können einfach viel
mehr als nur weihnachten und die gibt's
täglich und rund und ich nehme jetzt ja
ich nehme jetzt 70 millimeter vegan sind
sie auch nehme jetzt den mittleren eis
portionierer sodann habe ich immer die
gleich große portion hakt es doch drauf
und dann einfach und 210 der zweite
platte drauf und zusammendrücken ruhig
weiß was ich tricks mit der berger
presse dann wird es schon gleichmäßig
oas habe ich verdrückt ok etwas weniger
druck aber das ist cool
ja das mache ich das mal dann kann man
sie wirklich schön in die hand nehmen
hat keine klebrigen fingern und kann so
toll aus der hand essen ohne das sehr
aneinander kleben
ich finde von der größe her super sommer
riskiert also ablade
[Musik]
so zweite platte drauf und erst mal ganz
vorsichtig dass es sich verteilt und
damit schön glatt wird
[Musik]
vielleicht vielleicht muss ich dazu
sagen dass man die zweite platte
wirklich mit leichtem druck aber sehr
gefühlvoll auf die erste drückt damit
sie nicht bricht zwischen übrig also die
müslis max sind im concessions fertig
was jetzt noch machen könnte und was ich
auch mega süß finde also die sind
ungefähr zehn tage im kühlschrank
haltbar aber sondern halten den nicht
also bei uns nicht zwei tage oder sind
sie aufgefordert ein tag da sind sie
aufgefordert
was jetzt noch machen könnt wenn ihr das
für eure kinder macht oder führend
partner oder für euch selbst oder für
freunde ihr könnt lebensmittel
farbstifte nehmen und was dieses drauf
schreiben oder malen katzer für kinder
ich glaube für ella also ein regenbogen
ganz süße kinder ihrem mann oder frau
was drauf schreiben so was schönes prima
den müll raus nein verschafft ich liebe
dich und sind alles lebensmittel stifte
mit denen könnt ihr auf opladen malen
ich habe erfreut sich echte band
regenbogen und dann ist es ja auch
gleich mal attraktiver für kinder so
schön viel jemand okay es gibt schönere
regenbogen
[Musik]
das weit so variante eins also erst wo
der fruchtige müsli snacks ein bisschen
gleich nach orange schöne früchte mit
dabei und jetzt mache ich noch eine
schoko version aber ohne schokolade und
dafür habe ich hier schon gezuckt haben
sich neben 100 gramm haselnüsse 50 gramm
erdnüsse diesen gesalzen 50 gramm
cranberries 50 gramm datteln 20 gramm
äpfel 20 km amaranth 50 gramm
erdnussbutter 20 gramm kakao und 20
gramm kaunitz jetzt hier auch wieder das
gleiche spiel erstmal die nüsse und
früchte zerkleinern und auch hier könnt
ihr natürlich einfach wieder die zutaten
austauschen
die er nicht so gerne habt
cranberries wieder mit rabatten und
äpfel
ich mache auch immer ganz gerne
resteverwertung also wenn ich noch
offene nüsse früchte hat einfach alles
mit rein
und auch hier gebe ich am rand zum
schluss dass die erdnussbutter als
kleber cacau dazu für den
schokoladengeschmack und kaunitz und die
sind wirklich super denn man hat den
schokoladengeschmack aber ganz ohne
zucker kakao netz ist also gebrochene
kakaobohne und jetzt alles wieder schön
verrühren bzw
ich werde jetzt gleich wieder verkneten
aber ich sehe schon ich brauche etwas
erdnussbutter oder mehr früchte könnt
ihr auch nehmen damit es einfach schön
zusammenklebt schreibe ich dann die
korrigierte menge einfach auf ich habe
jetzt hier nochmal ein bisschen
erdnussbutter rein und nochmal daten
aber mehr ist die masse noch zu trocken
und dann ist mir angefangen ich habe
haferflocken vergessen
also werde ich doch noch kurz
haferflocken und orangensaft dazu geben
aber ich werde die haferflocken im
orangensaft kurzer kleine wenn jetzt
nach macht und experimentiert gerade ein
bisschen wenn ihr es nach macht dann
macht ihr einfach alle zutaten direkt in
mixa und dann kommt diese klebrige masse
auch dabei raus aber ihr seht schon ich
habe auch ein bisschen versucht meine
reste zu verwerten
und dann könnt ihr echt ein bisschen rum
experimentieren hauptsache die masse
wird klebrig damit sie formbar ist also
haferflocken orangensaft ich gebe auch
noch ein bisschen von der master dazu
[Applaus]
jetzt habe ich eine tolle konsistenz und
damit lässt sich jetzt alles auch gut
formen
[Musik]
und da müssen jetzt einfach mal
ausprobieren ob eure kinder des so mögen
es ist halt weniger süß als die dinge
die sie vielleicht songs kennen
aber ich muss auch echte zu sagen man
kann kinder dazu erzählen dass sie
einfach weniger service gewohnt sind
meine kinder zum beispiel die haben von
mir noch nie fruchtzwerge gekriegt oder
so ein fruchtjoghurt wir machen es
einfach selber ich nehme einfach ein
joghurt und naturjoghurt ganz ohne
zucker schweizer erdbeeren äpfel ein
bisschen zimtu oder pfirsiche und die
essen das dann als frucht joghurt und
dann muss man echt diese ganzen süßen
joghurt sorten aus dem supermarkt gar
nicht erst verfüttern und die gewöhnen
sich erst gar nicht an den süßen
geschmack die trinken auch einfach nur
wasser oder mal verdünnten saft mit
wasser und ich finde da muss man schon
böse gucken dass man die kinder weg von
dem ganzen zucker kriegt oder halt erst
gar nicht ran führt die rzb die ist also
die trinke nur wasser klar wenn sie
irgendwo man sieht dass jemand eine
fanta oder eine cola hat so was kriegst
du bei mir nicht aber ich kann sie dann
damit veräppeln dass ich dann sag' bis
den orangensaft und pudel wasser drauf
ist halt kinder fanta und dann trinkt
ihr das ja die samira dieter wissel
erwachsener die kann man nicht mehr so
leicht fällt
die probiert natürlich jetzt auch von
den sachen aus aber so bei den kleinen
kann man schon noch bissl tricksen und
herumexperimentieren okay hier nämlich
jetzt die kleineren back opladen die 50
mm habe ich einfach eine andere größe
nehme jetzt auch den kleinen eis
portionierer jetzt habe ich eine
perfekte klebrige masse und genau das
gleiche spiel
was er aber auch machen könnt falls ihr
sagt ich will das jetzt nicht so machen
dann könnt ihr auch kleine kugeln formen
und zum beispiel im gemahlenen nüssen
grenzen dann klebt es nicht mehr aber
ich finde so habt ihr einfach eine
schöne form und könnte sie auch
wunderbar lagern im kühlschrank schön
gestapelt und habt auch wirklich ganz
wenig platz verbraucht
ok so möchte sie im ersten probieren
also es ist eine schoko schnitte aber
ganz ehrliche meinung ist gut
ich mag es mit der schule nehmen kannst
du mit deinen freunden teilen
nüsse sind drin und haferflocken also
nichts für mir und ja nun aber alle
anderen dürfen essen gut komme das ist
ganz begeistert
das freut mich
[Musik]
guckt man jetzt kann ich dir einfach
schön luftdicht verpacken und im
kühlschrank lagern und dann den kindern
oder dem uhr ort einfach jeden morgen
mit geben so eher leisen kindergarten
samira trüben aber ein kind habe ich
trotzdem da sogar nachkommen wir sind
doch alle ein bisschen kennen ja das
stimmt
guckt mich an ich bin ein kind der 90er
heute siehst du bist was du so happy
happy von 90 erreicht ist ja also das
kleine müsli snacks zum mitnehmen
muskeln zu frühstücken
mal für die energie zwischendurch hier
so die großen diesen so fruchtig und die
sind schokolade probieren und
botschaften draufschreiben mit
lebensmittelfarbe dass endlich habe
meine mama ja früher noch klein sind ist
wenn ich dann halt gemacht bekommen habe
und dann so installieren auf viel erfolg
bei der mathearbeit das hat nicht
geklappt aber hier kommt viel erfolg
wenn man weiß das kind schreit
mathearbeit bitte schön viel erfolg
wünsche ich dir irgendwann bin ich ganz
aufgeregt aber wirklich statt der dennis
da kann nicht mehr so viel probieren da
unsere halt weg gaben geworden und immer
sehr lecker jedes mal wenn ich bei dir
probieren wahr gemacht
sehr lecker situation geraten und vor
allem ohne zusatz zucker weiter einfach
nur aus den früchten heraus müsse dabei
ungeschütztes kakaopulver und fertigt
ich hier gerne nicht nur regenbogen ja
weil das wetter so schön ist
statt für ella mache ich dann noch einen
drauf steht für da man kann es dem
freund mitnehmen
sie haben ja gestern zusammen gespielt
ja baby haben sie gespielt haben sie
mutter vater kind ja das habe ich auch
immer geschieht ich war schon im
kindergarten immer die mutter habe immer
alle versorgt gekocht gut dann kann man
die einfach so schön langsam und dann
dennis damit geben
so könnte auch wirklich auf vorrat
herstellen wie gesagt so zehn tage im
kühlschrank haltbar
bitte schön wenn wir schon das rezept
findet ihr auf salehs - blog de oder in
unserer kostenlosen app könnt euch
runterladen und das rezept ganz einfach
digital hochrechnen das heißt wenn ihr
sagt in die menge die reicht mir nicht
aus rechnet einfach hoch macht gleich
die doppelstreife vierfache menge mache
ich jetzt auch gleich noch mal also bis
zum nächsten mal
danke bitte
[Musik]